GUY WHO RAMMED HIS CAR INTO
HEATHER HEYER AND DOZENS MORE.
NOW, HERE'S AN INTERESTING
POINT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE IN A CIVIL
WAR TO BE IN A REAL WAR ON
CIVILITY AS WELL AS RULE OF LAW
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND THAT BRINGS US TO JANUARY 6.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A SITUATION MORE
UNDERPLAYED FOR POLITICAL EFFECT
IN ALL MY YEARS DOING THIS JOB.
YOU'VE GOT MORE THAN 660
DEFENDANTS CHARGED, AND ONE OF
THE TOUGHEST FELONY SENTENCES
YET GOES TO THE FACE OF THE
ABSURDITY OF THAT DAY, THE QANON
SHAMAN, JACOB CHANSLEY.
>> YEAH!
>> YEAH, THAT'S HIM.
THE JUDGE WHO HANDED DOWN THE
41-MONTH -- IT'S THREE-PLUS-YEAR
SENTENCE SAID FOR GOOD OR BAD HE
MADE HIMSELF THE VERY IMAGE OF
THIS WHOLE EVENT.
HE'S ACTUALLY A GOOD FACE FOR
IT, IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT IT.
THE RIDICULOUSNESS.
THE MISPLACED SENSE OF
PATRIOTISM, YOU KNOW, WITH THE
RED WHITE AND BLUE, WHATEVER HE
WAS GOING FOR THERE.
THE HORNS ON HIS HEAD.
CHANSLEY WAS ONE OF THE FIRST 30
RIOTERS INSIDE THE CAPITOL.
BUT YOU KNOW, IF YOU SUBTRACT
THE TIME SERVED, HE'S OUT BY
SUMMER 2024.
NOW, THAT SUMMER IS ONE IN WHICH
MANY NOW EXPECT DONALD TRUMP
WILL SEEK THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION FOR PRESIDENT ONCE
AGAIN.
AND YET THE SHAMAN'S LAWYER SAYS
THE REAL PERSON BEHIND JANUARY
6th IS THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> I WILL SAY THAT I WOULD
PROBABLY BE FAR MORE EFFECTIVE
OVER A BEER WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I'D TELL HIM
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'VE GOT [ BLEEP ] THINGS TO
DO.
CLEAR THIS [ BLEEP ] MESS UP AND
TAKE CARE OF A LOT OF THE
[ BLEEP ] THAT YOU [ BLEEP ] UP
ON JANUARY 6th.
>> WITH ME NOW IS CHANSLEY'S
ATTORNEY AL WATKINS.
COUNSELOR, WELCOME BACK TO
"PRIME TIME."
>> HOW DO YOU DO?
A PLEASURE.
>> THE SENTENCE WAS FOR THE
OFFENSE OF DISRUPTING AN
OFFICIAL PROCEEDING.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> OBSTRUCTION.
YES.
FELONY.
>> AND IN TERMS OF THE SENTENCE
THE ONLY REAL ISSUE IS WHETHER
OR NOT YOU BELIEVE THAT YOUR
CLIENT IS COMPETENT, MEANING
THAT IT'S NOT MENTAL ILLNESS
THAT MADE HIM DO THIS.
WHAT IS YOUR POSITION ON THAT?
>> NO.
THIS IS NOT A COMPETENCY ISSUE.
IT'S NOT A GUILT ISSUE.
MY CLIENT PLED GUILTY.
A COURT CONDUCTED AND ORDERED A
FORENSIC PSYCH EXAM.
THE DETERMINATION WAS THAT YES
INDEED, MY CLIENT HAD A VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND LONG-STANDING
MENTAL HEALTH VULNERABILITY BUT
WAS COMPETENT, JUST LIKE THE
MILITARY IN 2006 DIAGNOSED MY
CLIENT WITH THAT SAME
SIGNIFICANT LIFELONG MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDER.
ONLY IN 2006 THEIR ISSUE WAS IS
HE FIT FOR DUTY.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND IN 2006 THEY DIDN'T TELL
MY CLIENT ABOUT THAT
VULNERABILITY, THAT DISORDER.
MY CLIENT HAD A 15-YEAR WINDOW
WHERE HE COULD HAVE GOTTEN
TREATMENT, HE COULD HAVE GOTTEN
COUNSELING, HE COULD HAVE GOTTEN
ASSISTANCE DEALING WITH THAT
DISORDER.
BUT YOU KNOW, WITH MENTAL HEALTH
WE TREAT THAT LIKE WE NEED TO
SHROUD IT IN SECRECY.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND IT'S NOT RIGHT.
>> IT'S DEFINITELY A STIGMA.
AND YOU SAY THAT THAT IS PART OF
THE RECIPE THAT MADE HIM
VULNERABLE TO THE ENTREATIES OF
TRUMP AND OTHERS ABOUT JANUARY
6.
HE'S GOING TO SERVE HIS --
>> NO.
NO.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
YOU KNOW, JAKE MADE A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT IN FRONT OF THIS
COURT.
AND THAT WAS NOT ONLY WAS HE
ACCOUNTABLE BUT HE WANTED TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
JAKE MADE IT CLEAR, I MADE IT
CLEAR TO THE COURT THAT INDEED
THIS WAS NOT ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP, THIS WASN'T ABOUT WHETHER
HE SHOULD BE PARDONED, THIS WAS
ABOUT JAKE HOLDING HIMSELF
ACCOUNTABLE AND DOING SO IN A
REMARKABLY ARTICULATE AND
PROFOUNDLY CANDID FASHION THAT
WAS RECOGNIZED BY THE COURT AS A
MATTER OF PUBLIC RECORD AS BEING
SOMETHING THAT JUDGE HAD NEVER
SEEN IN 35 YEARS AS A FEDERAL
JUDGE.
>> I MEAN, THAT COULD GO JUST
FOR THE GUY'S OUTFIT.
HE HASN'T SEEN THAT IN 35 YEARS
EITHER.
>> WELL, THAT'S SORT OF GIVEN US
BOTH A CLUE.
A GUY HALF NUDE --
>> MAYBE, MAYBE NOT.
ALL I'LL SAY IS THIS, THOUGH,
COUNSELOR, THIS IS NOT WHERE
HE'S ALWAYS BEEN, YOUR CLIENT.
FOR A WHILE HIS STORY WAS OH, I
WASN'T DOING ANYTHING IN THERE,
I WAS TRYING TO STOP PEOPLE, I
WAS TRYING TO HELP.
SO IT'S GOOD THAT HE EVENTUALLY
WANTED TO KIND OF OWN THE
REALITY.
NOW, MY QUESTION TO YOU IS DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THESE CRIMES
AND THE BEHAVIOR OF THAT DAY
NEEDS TO INCLUDE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OR NOT?
>> YOU KNOW, LOOK, I SAID TO
EVERYBODY AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE THE OTHER DAY, MY
OPINION ISN'T WORTH ANYTHING.
THAT BEING SAID, IF I'M ASKED
FOR MY OPINION, I'M NOT SHY
ABOUT SHARING IT.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THERE IS A DUTY AND AN
OBLIGATION OF A FORMER PRESIDENT
TO BELLY UP TO THE BAR AND SAY
HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF I REALLY DO LOVE THEM AND I
REALLY DO THINK THEY'RE
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE AND I TOLD THEM
TO DO THIS MAYBE I SHOULD CLEAN
THINGS UP A LITTLE BIT.
>> IS THAT WHAT YOU MEANT WITH
YOUR COLORFUL LANGUAGE OUTSIDE
THE COURT?
>> OH, YEAH, LOOK, I COME FROM A
BIG OLD ITALIAN FAMILY WHO GREW
UP WITH A LOT OF COARSE
LANGUAGE.
YOU MAY UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
IT'S TIME FOR US TO REALLY KEEP
IT SIMPLE.
WHEN SOMEBODY HAS A PROBLEM,
IT'S REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT TO
GET YOUR MESSAGE OUT SO IT'S
UNDERSTOOD.
WE'VE GOT A FORMER PRESIDENT
WHO'S REALLY SCREWED UP A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
I'M NOT SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT
THE POLITICAL END OF IT.
NOT MY BUSINESS.
NOT MY ROLE.
I'M AN ADVOCATE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU MESS WITH PEOPLE, YOU MESS
WITH THEIR HEADS, AND YOU PUT
THEM IN A POSITION LIKE THAT,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
OWN IT THAT YOU SCREWED IT UP.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ONE OTHER
THING.
IN THE COURSE OF YOUR
REPRESENTATION HERE AND THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE ON THE CASE AND WHAT
THE ATMOSPHERE WAS LIKE AND WHAT
THE CONSTITUENCIES WERE ABOUT,
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT THERE ARE
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT HAVEN'T COME TO THE
REALIZATION THAT YOUR CLIENT
HAS, THAT AREN'T GOING TO BE
INCARCERATED THAT ARE STILL OUT
THERE, STILL LISTENING AND MAY
WANT TO ACT IN SIMILAR FASHION?
>> YEAH, I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT IT AND I SEE IT, I BREATHE
IT, I LIVE IT.
AND IT'S OUT THERE.
YOU HAVE A REALLY HEALTHY
PERCENTAGE OF OUR POPULATION,
INCLUDING MANY WHO HAVE BEEN
CHARGED FOR EVENTS OCCURRING ON
JANUARY 6th BUT HAVE BEEN
RELEASED.
IN THE CASE OF JACOB AND IN THE
CASE OF OTHERS THERE IS A --
THERE IS A CALMING EFFECT,
ALBEIT NOT ONE THAT'S HEALTHY
FOR SOMEONE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS, THERE'S A CALMING
EFFECT ABOUT BEING ALONE, ABOUT
BEING CONTEMPLATIVE,
INTROSPECTIVE.
AND TRULY WITH A GUY WHO'S
DISCIPLINED LIKE JAKE ABLE TO
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT?
I NEED TO EXTRICATE MYSELF, I
NEED TO PULL MYSELF UP OUT OF
THIS MUCK AND MIRE AND I NEED TO
OWN WHAT I DID.
AND JAKE IS NOT AN EXAMPLE TO BE
MADE OF BY THE GOVERNMENT.
JAKE TRULY SERVES AS AN EXAMPLE
FOR OTHERS.
>> WELL, I THINK HE'S GOING TO
BE BOTH, RIGHT?
BECAUSE THE FLAMBOYANCE, THE
BRAZENNESS OF HOW HE WENT IN
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT THE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT WANTED TO
MAKE VERY CLEAR WILL NOT STAND.
>> THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
BUT THAT AMERICAN GOVERNMENT IS
THE SAME GOVERNMENT THAT DID NOT
TELL JAKE IN 2006 THAT HE HAD A
DISORDER.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE BRAZENNESS
OF JAKE.
I CAN TALK ABOUT IT.
HE'S A GENTLE, LOVING, REALLY
SMART MAN.
>> HE ALSO WALKED WITH A HUGE
SPEAR INTO THE U.S. CAPITOL
UNDER BAD PRETENSES WITH A GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT W